more nevadan's return to the office
events and entertainment venues are
reopened
there is one crucial service that's also
available christian casadas joining us
now live in studio to explain why the
rape crisis center
plays such a vital role in emergency
response that's right denise
while online services and those from law
enforcement never
stop during the pandemic the rape crisis
center is resuming their in-person aid
to better assist the community an
individual experience to help overcome
a current or past assault there is
definitely no need to suffer in silence
a clear and powerful message the rape
crisis center
wants everyone to hear having access to
um support and resources is is so
so important um and you know not
everybody is ready
to reach out at the same time you know
some people
do seek services and support immediately
after something happens
some people don't seek services and
support until decades after something
happens
so we you know totally recognize that
that is a very individual choice
as nevada transitions to post-pandemic
life executive director danielle staple
says in-person services have resumed at
umc
and police stations with free exams
available with all the economic
pressures of the last year may have had
to double up maybe they weren't in safe
situations
but they couldn't necessarily report or
reach out for help
based on their situation founded over 45
years ago
this organization offers counseling to
almost 150 individuals
each month and increasing counseling
hours by 36 percent
since 2018 their key support is being
there when the victim
is ready what we really want folks to
focus on
is what will meet their needs and help
them
the most in you know moving forward